put it right there my lips are like
honestly the one thing that I feel like
I don't like love about my face I feel
like growing up I've started to get more
and more critical of how I love you feel
like they're just really thin and
there's not much shape to them like
they're just kind of like I never really
thought about changing my lips until
like I saw all these images and was like
I wish I looked like that it's just like
so hot right now to have really nice
puckered up beautiful lips all these
women and men are aspiring to look like
these celebrities it does make you want
to change things about yourself
I'm dr. Andre Berger and we're at
rejuvenate allottee Institute in Beverly
Hills California the mecca of aesthetic
medicine and surgery we've got two
really pretty girls here today and they
would like to just give a little more
enhancement to their already beautiful
lips they're gonna be like a side angle
difference afterwards yeah really yeah
oh so you have great lips you like
greater lips yeah I want them to be
bigger okay so what we have to do is
want to give you more volume but we want
to match your face too so what we're
gonna try and do is give you a really
pretty enhancement but you already have
pretty lips you just try to make them a
little more pretty me on the other
slightly different hey looks aren't
quite as nice as they are in the future
beautiful oh thank you in your case
however the difference is your field
trip is kind of a little bit flat so we
want to enhance the Cupid's bow and give
you a little more of a philtrum I'll
just kind of bring that lip up a little
bit is it dangerous at all to do this
not if I do it I'm excited I'm really
I'm really excited now I'm just I'm
really nervous I'm nervous for the
procedure like needles scare me a little
bit I mean I'm a little nervous like for
them to get up to be honest it's like
weird to like put your trust in someone
else for your face I'm first yeah I
literally can't play this is real life
right now okay honestly like even though
we had a consultation I feel like I
don't know like what's gonna actually
happen like right now we were joking
back there like a few months like oh
yeah that'd be so funny if we got lip
injections and now it's like the moment
is literally here yeah
what if they're never the same like what
if they're never the same again I'm
gonna have a little numbing stuff I lied
the gum here before I checked it
another little numbing medicine okay
how's that feel sometimes okay Larry now
oh god no now we're not so good for the
way
you
my god I'm like scared to look like I'm
obviously wanted to do what I'm like
this again Wow Wow yeah it's a lot
different I'm overwhelmed right now
congratulations thank you have some ice
on you now okay didn't hurt did it
no it didn't there you go beautiful lips
no Kate I can't we actually did that I
feel myself I can't feel my face at all
so it's the 10 o'clock at night and I'm
laying in my bed and it's like really
sore I can kind of like see him anxiety
like it feels like kind of like soul and
this point I'm like damn was this really
worth how I feel right now
my opinion of lip injections has
definitely changed over the course of
this last week one thing I hadn't
considered beforehand was that it would
actually hurt and I would actually be in
physical pain afterwards I thought going
into it that I was going to just be like
a couple needles there a couple nails
clear then you're done and then you have
nice plum plaits but it was actually
like this whole thing now I know that
it's a lot more serious and it's not
something that you should take lightly
after they numbed my lips I had this
moment where I was sitting there and I
thought what did I get myself into we
talk about celebrities and like oh she
got her lips done and we don't really
talk about the fact that there are
actual people and they actually had to
go into the doctor's office get needles
in their face I probably wouldn't do it
again just because
whole thing was so involved I feel like
I'm really 50/50 on if I would and I
actually like it and I'm getting more
used to it but also knowing all of the
things that go into getting it I think
overall we're just too critical
everyone has a really great lives I
definitely have a new appreciation for
my old flips I don't think that they are
as bad as I thought they were if you
want to make a change it happy because
you want it not because what other
people are going to say or think about
it